[Music]
back in march of this year something
happened which i definitely did not
expect when i started my channel a
little over two years ago over ten
thousand of you wait no that's not right
over one hundred thousand of you
apparently found my content worthy
enough to hit that subscribe button and
just a few weeks later this guy came
into the mail it still boggles the mind
a bit when i think about numbers like
these i mean monster maze started as
sort of a side hobby during the early
stages of the pandemic something to
focus on while i waited for new
animation jobs i guess you could say i
was bored i will never be able to
express my thanks enough to all of you
who stuck with the channel throughout
the past two years zelda news has been
pretty scarce during this period i guess
i didn't exactly choose the best time to
start a channel like this and yet you
continue to show up to show your love
for the series and keep the hype for
breath to all 2 alive it goes to show
how much the fans love these games and
will continue to talk about them even
when there's not a lot of activity on
the side of nintendo as per tradition
with every milestone today's video is
for the viewers by the viewers a few
weeks ago i asked you guys to share your
own zelda theories with me 15 of which i
have selected to be featured right here
on the channel however during the
writing process i quickly realized that
covering 15 separate theories in one
single video was perhaps a bit too
ambitious on my part it worked fine for
things like items and dungeon ideas
since they don't require backstory and
research but a theory is simply not
something you can spell out in under a
minute or so i would have to cut some
serious corners and skip over a lot of
details in order to fit all 15 within a
reasonable run time without working
myself to near exhaustion i want to give
each and every one of your ideas the
love and attention it deserves otherwise
what's the point in covering them if i'm
just gonna rush through them right still
i did promise 15 so i decided to split
it up into three separate videos which
will feature five theories each once
again it was very difficult for me to
choose from so many great ideas and
topics and if your theory didn't make it
in please don't feel bad about it it
doesn't mean your idea wasn't good
enough and there will be more of these
types of videos in the future there were
quite a lot of breathed wild and in
particular breath 202 related theories
so i try to balance it out just a little
bit by including some theories that
encompass other games in the series as
well furthermore the theories presented
here today are in no particular order
meaning their placement in the list says
nothing about which theory i think is
best this isn't a contest or anything
like that so without further ado let's
take a look at the first 5 zelda
theories by the viewers
despite not being my favorite zelda game
the wind waker will always have a
special place in my heart the great sea
is such an amazing place to explore it's
vast mysterious and filled to the brim
with all kinds of stories secrets and
legends passed down by sailors and
explorers who tried their luck out at
sea tales of treasure giant squids
unusual storms and much more are the
talk of the town here when i think of
adventure i think about the wind waker
and what would a seafaring adventure be
without a good old-fashioned ghost ship
it's as classic as it can get right up
there with the kraken and the giant
whale this mysterious haunted vessel
manifests in different locations on the
great sea depending on the phase of the
moon and its appearance is signified by
a foreboding shift in weather dark
clouds rain and lightning accompanied by
a haunting music score that swells up
the closer you get to it from afar it
appears as a series of blue lights
seemingly hovering in formation but as
you peer into the darkness a bit closer
the semi-transparent shape of the ship
itself starts to become visible link
won't be able to board the ship right
from the get-go as he'll just pass
through it unless he's in possession of
a special chart the ghost ship chart
once obtained instead of just passing
through link will instead be transported
to the ship's interior despite being one
of the most creepy and exciting
encounters in the game we barely know
anything about it there's no explanation
about its existence or why it continues
to haunt the seas whatsoever al exposure
suggests that it could have something to
do with the triforce depending on which
version of the game you play the ship
holds either a piece of the triforce of
courage or a treasure map leading to set
piece i'd say that in both instances
those on board were hiding it from the
rest of the world it's just that in the
hd version they removed the extra step
of having to go dig it up somewhere to
make the quest less cumbersome i think
it's definitely possible that being in
possession of a piece of the holy relic
somehow led to the ship and its crew
getting cursed even though the triforce
is generally seen as something positive
a divine gift historically it's also
driven certain people into a state of
madness greed betrayal and even outright
murder sometimes of their own comrades
so it's not unthinkable that even a
small piece of it can lead to some dire
consequences especially if its power was
never meant for them alternatively it
could have attracted some sort of
demonic presence similar to the ghost
ship from phantom hourglass which isn't
the same vessel as the two don't look
anything alike but is under the control
of bellum who is classified as a demon i
think it's all but certain that there is
a connection between the unfortunate
fate of those on board and the triforce
of courage because as soon as link
obtains it a blood-curdling screech can
be heard echoing from within the hull
after which the ghost ship and its
undead crew disappear forever the curse
seemingly having been lifted so who
exactly were these people and what were
their intentions alex proposes a couple
of different options a that the ship and
its crew could have been pirates
possibly originating from the forsaken
fortress who stole a piece of the holy
relic perhaps for nefarious reasons b
that those on board were innocent just a
group of explorers who happened to
stumble on the triforce piece by
accident or see that the ship and its
crew were actually entrusted with
protecting the triforce piece and may
even linger in the afterlife by their
own free will to continue to do so a bit
like how the shika in breath the wild
mummified themselves to draw out their
existence in fact alex even suggests
that it could have been a shika vessel
now as far as we know the shika are
completely absent from the adult
timeline then again there are some small
references to the shika that have
persisted even in this age and suppose
this ship did indeed originate from the
forsaken fortress there is one symbol
present here which bears a strong
resemblance to the shikai symbol the
forsaken fortress is a mystery all on
its own in the present day it's under
the control of ganondorf but as far as
we know this wasn't always the case
after all ganondorf broke free from his
seal only recently so before that the
fortress would have been either
abandoned or in the hands of a different
faction a faction possibly related to
the chica so let's put the facts on the
table here and see which option is the
most likely first is the ship itself one
thing that stands out about it is that
even though it looks fairly similar to
the pirate ship belonging to tetra and
her crew there are some notable
differences instead of a black flag
featuring the typical skull and bones
the ghost ship dons a white flag with a
blue stripe in the middle it also lacks
the skull and bones on the side as seen
on the pirate ship belonging to tetra
the statue on the front of the ship also
known as the figurehead looks to be that
of a person praying a stark contrast to
the more menacing serpent-like statue
seen on the pirate ship all this leads
me to believe that this was not a pirate
ship but instead something akin to a
private or commercial vessel second is
the fact that although the ship seems
relatively harmless to link himself it
is known to have caused some serious
damage to others the man who drew the
ghost ship chart and mapped out the
ship's movement is said to have died a
most unexpected death then there's lenzo
the photographer at windfall island who
managed to snap a picture of the ghost
ship he claims to have gotten
shipwrecked right before it made its
appearance and david junior one of
tingle's uh
helpers is said to have been in pursuit
of the treasure aboard the ghost ship
before being washed up on tingo island
and his now deceased father is said to
have seen the haunted vessel as well it
could even be that the man who died
shortly after mapping out the ship's
movement is none other than david's
father so whatever the intentions of
those in control of the ship are they
are no stranger to causing harm and even
death to those trying to unravel its
secrets what's also interesting is the
location where the ghost ship chart is
found which is inside a cave on diamond
step island the cave looks to be some
sort of ship graveyard what these old
worn down ships are doing down here is a
complete mystery why are they on the
ground and how did they even get here
nintendo black crisis once suggested to
me that the water levels of the great
sea may have been different in the past
either higher or lower this would
explain why these shipwrecks are located
deep down as the island itself may have
at one point had an entrance leading to
its interior which could have collapsed
as the sea level started to rise closing
it off from the outside world there's
another cave just like this one on
needle rock island as well and if
anything these old retired vessels are a
clear indication that a lot more ships
like these used to sail the great sea
ones that were similar to the ghost ship
but have since been abandoned perhaps
they belong to the early survivors of
the great flood maybe they were
salvaging treasure and materials from
the old kingdom and use them to build
the towns and villages we see today who
knows either way the appearance of the
ship as well as the horrible effects it
had on innocent lives definitely leans
more towards a malicious curse as
opposed to a valiant attempt to protect
the triforce from falling into the wrong
hands whoever these people were they
seemed to have stumbled onto a power
that was perhaps too much for them to
control whether that's the effects of
the triforce itself or some sort of evil
presence it may have attracted i
definitely don't want to completely rule
out a possible sheikah connection as we
do find clues and references to them on
the great sea perhaps some remnants or
descendants of the shika did survive the
great flood and continued to guard the
triforce even in the afterlife or maybe
these really were just random explorers
who found the triforce by accident
cursed to sail the seas for all eternity
unless someone came along to put them
out of their misery
the barbarian outfit is one of my
favorite armor sets in breath the wild
it's powerful it looks badass and if
you're efficient at taking down lynels
it's easily upgradable too according to
the description of the armor set the
decorative paint that comes with the
outfit bolsters your fighting spirit and
wearing it increases link's attack power
those who are associated with the outfit
the ever so mysterious zonai seem to
have had an affinity with raw power and
brute strength which fits their general
description although their main capital
seems to have been located at the spring
of courage everything else about them
suggested tribe who valued power this is
reflected by terms like savage barbarian
and warlike as well as the effects of
the armor itself jackson campbell
proposes the idea that the war paint the
barbarians used for their armor could in
fact be infused with malice the infamous
byproduct of ganon's hatred seen all
across hyrule the reasoning behind this
connection is that some of the stronger
variants of bokoblins moblins lisophos
and linos have similar paint-like
patterns on their body now the game
doesn't outright say that these patterns
are the result of malice but it does
suggest that these types of enemies have
been influenced by ganon's fiendish
magic making them stronger than their
other counterparts and indeed it's hard
to ignore the similarities between the
war paint on the barbarian armor and
those found on ganon's minions
particularly the silver variants
according to jackson this could be yet
another indication that the zonai may
not have been the friendly neighborhood
savages we thought them out to be zeltiq
and i have previously covered the
possibility that the zonai may have had
some sort of allegiance with ganondorf
in the distant past in our collaboration
we pointed to the architecture and cave
painting seen in the sequel footage many
of which feature themes and motifs
related to the demon king also one can't
help but see the similarities in the red
flowing hair on the barbarian helmet and
ganon's iconic red mane from past games
and while this is yet another one of
those possible connections that could
point to some sort of relationship
between the zonai and ganondorf ganon
this supposed alliance could have been
tarnished a long time ago and the
barbarians of farron may not feel the
same way about him now if they're even
alive still i think it's an interesting
idea that the zonai could have taken
inspiration from ganondorf covering
their bodies in a similar war paint as
seen on the silver monster types to
bring out the beast inside them
alternatively it could have been the
other way around and it's ganon who
adapted the customs of the zonai instead
i can't say for sure if the paint itself
is indeed related to malice specifically
but it's most certainly more than just
regular paint and is related to magic
the zonai are said to have been powerful
magic wielders as is ganondorf so
whoever copied who it's more than
possible that the two phenomena are one
and the same
[Music]
next is a theory by azul nova who
suggests that link from the wind waker
may have a distant ancestor many of us
are familiar with at the end of ocarina
of time princess zelda sends the hero of
time back seven years to catch up on his
lost childhood causing this part of the
timeline to split into two the child
branch where link continues his
adventures as a kid and the adult branch
where he is erased from existence and
hyrule is left without a hero altogether
this ended up being pretty bad for those
left behind though as ganondorf broke
free from his presence shortly after
plunging the kingdom into yet another
war for the triforce and without a hero
to stop him the gods themselves had to
intervene by flooding the entire kingdom
in a torrential downpour giving birth to
the great sea because the hero of time
ceased to exist in this timeline right
after his quest was completed he
couldn't possibly have had offspring as
such it's often speculated that the link
we see in the wind waker is just some
kid a kid who happens to grow into a
proper hero out of pure necessity link
is just a boy living on an island with
his family and coincidentally gets mixed
up in something bigger when his beloved
sister got mistaken for someone else and
got kidnapped the game itself emphasizes
on more than one occasion that he is not
the legendary hero they have been
looking for for so long the fabled hero
of time who they hoped would make a
return someday in his absence the boy
from outset island had to prove himself
to the gods and earned the triforce of
courage in the process to show that he
had what it takes to be a champion for
good and ultimately face ganondorf this
is in stark contrast to not only the
hero of time but also his descendant
from the child timeline the hero of
twilight from the moment they were born
they were predestined to become the
god's chosen hero especially in the case
of the hero of time who was a child of
prophecy both heroes have the triforce
symbol on the back of their hands
seemingly from birth and neither had to
prove their competence to the gods first
they were always destined for greatness
something that wasn't the case for link
in the wind waker he became a hero kind
of by accident really but what if he did
have a blood connection to a past hero
one who lived long before the events of
ocarina of time after all the hero of
time was by no means the first in line
there's at least three heroes that have
preceded him possibly even more like the
hero of men from minish cap's backstory
who we don't know much about and that is
exactly what azul suggests that link
from the wind waker could be a distant
relative of another hero specifically
link from diminish cap there's of course
the obvious similarities in their
physical appearance however this can
easily be chalked up to art style after
all there are similar looking heroes
from completely different timelines as
well now azul's reasoning for a blood
connection between these two is a lot
more subtle a tiny detail both literally
and figuratively that being the hero
shield according to link's grandmother
the shield is a family heirloom another
ceremonial artifact passed down from the
old days and the in-game description
states that it is said to have been
wielded by the legendary hero himself
it's implied that this is referring to
the hero of time as it's the only past
hero mentioned in the game's story
however this doesn't make much sense
when you really think about it the hero
of time utilized the hylian shield
during most of his adventure and
depending on your own fashion choice he
brandishes either the hylian shield or
the mirror shield at the moment he was
sent back in time now you could say that
well maybe the shield from the wind
waker is supposed to represent the
hylian shield again differences in art
style but if so why are these two
shields so radically different it's not
just a name that's different but the
size shape even the material doesn't
match in the slightest the hylian shield
is a sturdy high quality metal shield
whereas the hero shield is mostly made
of wood and overall pretty cheap looking
even tetra jokes about its quality
there's of course the difference in
color and perhaps most notably the size
the hero shield is incredibly small even
in the hands of a young child in fact it
seems to have been specifically made for
children compare this to the hylian
shield which is so big that as a child
link couldn't even hold it up like
normal and instead had to use it as a
turtle shell it's almost as big as he is
now that i think about it i'm pretty
sure the hylian shield traveled back
seven years with the hero of time right
to me the differences between the two
are simply too big to conclude that it's
the same shield but in a different art
style and why change the name if it
really was supposed to be one in the
same now there is a shield bearing the
same name present in the child timeline
the one link starts out with in majora's
mask while it's definitely smaller than
the hylian shield again the material and
color doesn't match we also have no idea
how exactly link got his hands on this
shield and more importantly he obtained
it in a completely different timeline as
a child long story short the hero of
time and hero of winds cannot be related
by blood and based on its physical
appearance and chronologically speaking
the hero shield is almost certainly not
the same as either of the two shields
the hero of time use it simply doesn't
match but like azul points out there is
a shield which does resemble the one
from the wind waker that being the tiny
shield from the minish cap which link is
seen carrying right there on the front
cover it's pretty much an exact match
right down to the color the size and the
decorations if this is indeed the same
shield it would be compelling evidence
that the heroes from minish cap and the
wind waker could share a blood
connection after all how did it end up
getting passed down in link's family for
all these countless ages the description
mentioned before never elaborates on
which hero used to wield it it doesn't
specifically say the hero of time so
could this instead be referencing a
different individual a hero who lived
long before the events of ocarina of
time and whose bloodline has survived
all the way up until now it would
explain why link despite being such a
young kid possesses so much strength and
courage seemingly for no reason other
than he's the hero of the story defying
the odds and slaying one of the most
dangerous individuals to walk this earth
all before even reaching adulthood and a
possible blood relation to the hero of
diminish could have given this unlikely
hero the edge he needed to fulfill his
goals whatever the case may be the idea
that this shield survived and was passed
down ever since the age of minish cap is
very compelling to me not because it's
magical or of exceptional quality
because frankly the opposite is true
it's a cheap simple tiny little shield
and there may have been many more like
it in its time but unlike the hylian
shield which was simply bought from a
random bazaar the hero shield has a
symbolic and sentimental value attached
to it it was a gift from one of the
earliest incarnations of princess zelda
herself an act of kindness and
generosity between two childhood friends
and one that ended up being
indispensable in link's quest to defeat
vati it's confirmed that the shield of
antiquity from spirit tracks is also the
very same one the hero of winds used on
his adventure kept safe and treasured by
his old friend nico so not only did it
survive from minish cap all the way up
until the wind waker but it even
persisted all the way up to the very end
of the adult timeline in a newly
established kingdom no less
this next theory is something i never
really thought about until now but
actually makes a lot of sense ocarina of
time first introduced the gerudo the
strong and proud women of the scorching
desert their biology somehow dictates
that almost everyone born into the tribe
is female with only one male being born
every 100 years during this age it was
custom for the male to become the
tribe's leader and the only male gerudo
we've met so far is of course the man
with the sinister plan ganondorf despite
being a familiar face in zelda lore the
gerudo only make an appearance in 5
games ganondorf not included of course
and in the case of majora's mask it's
debatable if these even are real gerudo
or just pirates with the same character
model the reason why the gerudo don't
appear very often in the timeline is
exactly because of their connection and
loyalty to ganondorf in every outcome
following ocarina of time ganondorf
suffers a temporary defeat in the chow
timeline he's captured and sealed inside
the twilight realm in the adult timeline
he's frozen at the bottom of the sea
along with the entire kingdom and in the
downfall timeline during the imprisoning
war he is banished to the dark world
formerly known as the sacred realm as
such the absence of the gerudo following
the timeline split makes sense in
twilight princess the desert is barren
and empty and it's implied that the
gerudo have either been killed or exiled
after ganondorf's capture they do show
up again in relatively large numbers in
four swords adventures this time as a
peaceful tribe who want nothing to do
with ganondorf so i'm inclined to
believe that some did manage to escape
persecution back then in the adult
timeline they are never seen again in
any of the games which leads me to
believe that they probably didn't
survive past the great flood when it
comes to the downfall timeline their
fate is equally uncertain the same type
of scenarios are possible of course they
could have been killed in the
imprisoning war or exiled the only
appearance of gerudo beside ganon are
kaume and kotake in orkov ages and
seasons which don't even take place in
hyrule aside from them it does seem to
suggest that the rest of the tribe may
not have survived this outcome either
whatever happened before the events of a
link to the past their presence name and
influence are all but a distant memory
seemingly wiped from the history books
brick colby has a logical yet kind of
disturbing explanation as to why the
gerudo are barely seen again in this
timeline one that emphasizes the sheer
brutality of ganondorf as a leader if we
study the backstory of a link to the
past from the instruction manual it says
that at some point the doors to the
sacred realm the resting place of the
triforce at the time were breached by a
gang of thieves and that ganon fought
his way past his own followers
vanquishing them and eventually standing
triumphant with blood-stained hands
claiming the triforce as his prize he
allegedly even made his wish right then
and there the first and only time ganon
has succeeded in getting his wish
granted by the triforce the band of
thieves described here fits the profile
of the gerudo as they are referred to as
search in ocarina of time now this
backstory is a bit outdated as it was
written long before the zelda team had a
solid grasp on if and how they wanted to
integrate this story into a larger
narrative there was no zelda timeline
back then but the part about ganondorf
vanquishing his own followers without a
second doubt is absolutely something he
would do his obsession and greed for
power rise far above things like loyalty
and kinship to him his followers
including his own tribe are but mere
tools to achieve his goal of world
domination they are disposable and thus
after breaching the doors to the sacred
realm and having laid his eyes on the
prize ganondorf made sure that no one
but him would be able to obtain it
perhaps out of fear that someone might
betray him and attempt to steal his wish
from under his nose his big gigantic
nose if this is true then it's a very
disturbing outcome for the gerudo in
this timeline massacred on mass by their
own former king their leader whom they
were fiercely loyal to if there's
anything unique about the downfall
timeline it's that it's the only one
where ganon never reverts back to his
human form instead he seems to have
completely given in to his monstrous
alter ego and with it any remaining
connection to his roots humanity and his
former life as a gerudo are all but lost
alongside his former people
this last one is by manny boy who thinks
that the choice to flip the timeline
placement of the oracle games and link's
awakening was a mistake and i agree
wholeheartedly to give a bit of context
the official zelda timeline confirms
that the hero from a link to the past
link's awakening and the oracle games
are all the same incarnation of link and
you know it makes sense that way first
he saved hyrule from ganon went out on
his own and experienced other adventures
until finally after many years had
passed a new hero would rise up in a
link between worlds now the first
edition of the zelda timeline introduced
these games in the following order a
link to the past first then the oracle
games and finally link's awakening to me
and many others this has always been the
most logical chronology however in the
most recent version of the timeline they
for some reason decided to flip the
order of the oracle games and link's
awakening which makes a lot less sense
and the evidence is in the backstories
of the games themselves according to the
manual of link's awakening after having
saved hyrule from ganon at the end of a
link to the past link desired to grow
stronger in case hyrule would ever come
under siege again in the future and so
he set out on a personal voyage outside
the borders of the kingdom it goes on to
say that when link got shipwrecked and
landed on coal and island he was
actually already on his way back to
hyrule seemingly having fulfilled his
personal quest already the personal
quest spoken about in the backstory of
link's awakening seems to fit with his
adventures in holodrim and labrana which
are indeed lands that lay outside the
borders of hyrule in order for the new
chronology to work we have to assume
that link first defeated ganon in hyrule
then went on an unknown quest we never
get to see attempts to sail back to
hyrule before getting stranded on coal
and island eventually does make it back
only to be summoned by the triforce to
go on yet another offshore adventure in
holodrum and labrena while not
impossible the fact that we have to
imagine a quest we never actually get to
experience is a bit messy considering
that they could have just as well
incorporated the adventures of the
oracle games to fit with the quest
spoken off in link's awakening's
backstory you know like it used to be
before the order was changed it's not
perfect and it doesn't all fit nice and
snug for instance link didn't set out on
a journey he was kind of sort of forced
to go by the will of the triforce but
it's a voyage nonetheless link never
actually sails to labreno or holodrum
instead he gets teleported there but we
never see him getting teleported back to
hyrule after he succeeds either the
triforce can only provide a one-way
ticket or it's just being a dick but
that's beside the point either way after
concluding his quest in these respective
lands he would have had to find a way
back to hyrule on his own thus he set
sail for hyrule but before making it to
his final destination his vessel gets
hit by lightning and the story of link's
awakening picks up again by no means
perfect but i prefer not having to
imagine a quest that happens off screen
over a small inconsistency in the
backstory we of course have to remember
that a link to the past and link's
awakening were written long before the
oracle games not only that but the
oracle games were made by capcom so i
can forgive a few discrepancies in the
storytelling here and with a little bit
of creativity we can make this work yes
link technically didn't set out on a
journey on his own and was instead
summoned by the triforce but as we can
see in the intro he did travel to the
castle on horseback willingly to seek
audience with it so we can still kind of
consider this a personal quest either
way seeing as breath wild has kind of
wiped the slate clean it's unlikely that
the timeline will ever get updated and
even if it does they probably won't
bother with such an insignificant detail
but to me the old chronology of these
four games will always make more sense
to me unless someone comes up with a
solid theory that convinces me otherwise
and that concludes part 1 of your zelda
theories part 2 and 3 will follow soon
however i will spread them out a bit
across the rest of the year in between
other videos i have a lot more subjects
and ideas i really want to get to and i
don't want to hold these back for too
long i like mixing things up and variety
is a big part of my enjoyment as a
creator once again i cannot thank you
all enough for the support and for
getting the channel this far as always a
huge thanks goes to my mods on discord
and my live streams and of course to my
amazing patreons and channel members
once again i have a few new faces to
announce so give it up for faraday
edward studio campbell grand
nerdific.com mr return and julian
clement thank you all so much for
joining and and that is all for now this
is don signing off and have a good one
[Music]
you